carved into soft stone the meaning of
these symbols lost to us today
but this 5 000 year old chalk drum on
show for the first time gives an
emotional insight into life back then
it was found many miles to the north of
stonehenge in a grave site that was
unearthed in east yorkshire and what
archaeologists found alongside it was
just as interesting they found the
bodies of three children aged between 3
and 12 in a pose like they've never seen
before
the youngest two facing each other
touching hands the eldest placing his or
her arms around them almost cuddling
buried with a clay ball that a child
might play with it's incredibly poignant
and it moves people to tears and it it
shows a sort of vulnerability of the
children and you can only sort of relate
to and sympathize with the community at
the time the parents and the mourners
who buried those children
in the grave
it is the first time such a range of
objects from stonehenge times have been
brought together like this
of course it can't include stonehenge
but it does have the wooden seahenge
found by the shore in norfolk the
british museum setting out to explain
the advanced depths of the neolithic
community's knowledge
a good example of that is is these
beautiful axes on this wall behind us
usually they're stored away but they are
beautiful amazing objects and they're so
key to understanding this period um
which is about the transformation of
land in a sense the creation of the
world we know now the farming world
is an incredible insight into a time
whose people we know were sophisticated
enough to design and build stonehenge
but whose ways remain shrouded in
mystery katie spencer sky news